we know that if we had five people let's
say person a person B person C person D
and person E and we wanted to put them
in five different let's say positions or
chairs so position one position to
position three position four and
position five if we wanted to count the
number of scenarios or we could say the
number of permutations of putting these
five people in these five chairs well we
could say well we have five different if
we if we seated people in order which we
might as well do we could say look five
different people could sit in chair one
so for each of those scenarios four
different people could sit in chair two
now for each of these scenarios now so
we have 20 scenarios five five times
four we have twenty scenarios where
we've seated seat ones and seat 1 and C
2 how many people could we now seat in
seat three for each of those 20
scenarios well 3 people haven't sat down
yet so there's three possibilities there
so now there's five times four times
three scenarios for seating the first
three people how many people are left
for seat four well two people haven't
sat down yet so there's two
possibilities so now there's five times
four times three times two scenarios of
seating the first four seats and for
each of those how many possibilities are
there for the fifth seat well 1 / 4 each
of those scenarios we only have one
person who hasn't sat down left so
there's one possibility and so the
number of permutations the number of let
me write this down the number of
permutations permutations of seating
these five people in five chairs is five
factorial five factorial which is equal
to five times four times three times two
times one which of course is equal to C
twenty times six which is equal to 120
and we've already covered this in a
previous video but now let's do
something maybe more interesting or
maybe you might find it less interesting
let's say that we still have let's say
we have these five people but we don't
have as many chairs so not everyone is
going to be able to sit down so let's
say that we only
have three chairs so we have chair one
we have chair two and we have chair
three so how many ways can you have five
people where only three of them are
going to sit down in these three chairs
and we care which chair they sit in and
I encourage you to pause the video and
think about it so I am assuming you have
had your go at it so let's use the same
logic so how many if we're if we seat
them in order we might as well how many
different people if we haven't seen sat
anyone yet how many different people
could sit in seat one well we could have
no if no one sat down we have five
different people well five different
people could sit in seat one well for
each of these scenarios where one person
has already sat in seat one how many
people could sit in seat two well in
each of these scenarios if one person is
sat down there's four people left who
haven't been seated so four people could
sit in seat two so we have five times
four scenarios where we have seated
seats one and C two now for each of
those 20 scenarios how many people could
sit in seat three
well we haven't sat we haven't we
haven't Seaton or set three of the
people yet so for each of these twenty
we could put three different people in
seat three so that gives us five times
four times three scenarios so this is
equal to five times four times three
scenarios which is equal to this is
equal to 60 so there's 60 permutations
of sitting five people in three chairs
now this and this my brain you know
whenever I start to think in terms of
permutations I actually think in these
ways I just literally draw it out
because especially you know I don't like
formulas I like to actually
conceptualize and visualize what I'm
doing but you might say hey you know
when when we just did five different
people and five different chairs and we
cared which seat they sit in we had this
five factorial you know factorial is
kind of a neat little operation there
how can I relate factorial to what we
did to what we did just now well it
looks like we kind of did factorial but
then we stopped we stopped at we didn't
go times two times one so one way that
we one way to think about what we just
did
is we just did 5 times 4 times 3 times 2
times 1 but of course we actually didn't
do the 2 times 1 so you could take that
and you could divide by 2 times 1 and if
you did that then this 2 times 1 would
cancel with that 2 times so on and you'd
be left with 5 times 4 times 3 and the
whole reason I'm writing this way is
that now I could write it in terms of
factorial I could write this as 5
factorial 5 factorial over 2 factorial
over 2 factorial but then you might have
the question well where did this to come
from well you know I have 3 seats where
did this to come from well think about
it I multiplied 5 times 4 times 3 I kept
going until I had that many seats and
then I didn't do the remainder so the
number of so the things that I left out
the things that I left out that was
essentially the number of people minus
the number of chairs so I was trying to
put five things in three places so five
minus three that gave me two left over
so I could write it like this I could
write it as five I me were doing use
those same colors I could write it as
five factorial over over five minus
three which of course is two five minus
three factorial and so another way of
thinking about it if we wanted to
generalize is if you're trying to put if
you're trying to figure out the number
of permutations and there's a bunch of
notations for writing this if you're
trying to figure out the number of put
permutations where you could put n
people in our seats or the number of
permutations we could put n people in
our seats and there's other notations as
well well this is just going to be n
factorial over n minus R factorial here
n was 5 r was 3 and minus 5 minus 3 is 2
now you'll see this in a probability or
statistics class and and you know people
might memorize this thing it seems like
this kind of daunting thing I'll just
tell you right now the whole reason why
I just showed this to you is so that you
could connect it with
what you might see in your textbook or
what you might see in a class or when
you see this type of formula you see
that it's not you know coming out of you
know it's not some type of voodoo magic
but I will tell you that for me
personally I never use this formula I
always reason it through because if you
just memorize the formula I was only
wait that does this formula apply there
what's N what's R but if your reason it
through it comes out of straight logic
you don't have to memorize anything you
don't feel like you're just memorizing
without understanding you're just using
your deductive reasoning your logic and
that's especially valuable because as
we'll see
not every scenario is going to fit so
cleanly into what we did there might be
some tweaks on this we're like you know
maybe the only person be like sitting in
one of the chairs or who knows what it
might be and then your formula is going
to be useless so I like reasoning
through it like this but I just showed
you this so that you could connect it to
a formula that you might see in a
lecture or in a class